hello everybody i am playing crisis
today i'm going to put everything here
on can it run crisis
this video is sponsored by crytek uh the
game is on uh the epic game store right
now i really should have just done that
from the start huh but i have streamed
the first crisis recently and i feel
like i
we're gonna try we're gonna try
i feel like um i've spoken a number of
times about how much i absolutely love
crisis 3 especially that predator was so
cool and makes you feel like
a boss and now all of the crisises are
out uh fully remastered but i wanted to
do a test for the purposes of this
where i'm going to try to pull up
a youtube video where somebody's done a
walkthrough of
the first sections of the game and then
do a comparison with how each of the
remasters look so probably do like maybe
five minutes of each game i thought
would be a cool test
because for you youngans out there who
don't already know about this who
haven't heard about this
there has been this ongoing thing with
crisis specifically about it basically
like proving the worth of your pc hence
the literal settings in this game saying
can it run crisis
this is
crisis
one the game that came out in 2007. and
hit play on that and i'm going to start
my campaign at the same time
i think we're pretty close to messed up
so far very dark
this discovery could change the future
of the planet
i feel like there is already more detail
that i can see
i'm very impressed with how well
the difference in that lighting was so
good
hey no man you still with us
okay listen up gentlemen intel reports a
significant
presence
we have the element of surprise so let's
use it
this is really cool i've never tried to
line something up like this before
can it cycle the lighting on their faces
is so much better it like blends in
better
our job is to locate and evacuate we're
not in war here not yet
[Music]
this is so cool
i've never done this before it looks so
neat it's like a second apart but
okay
[Music]
no man what's your status
i'm okay i'm okay but my heart's
scrambling i feel like the clarity and
the water is way
better make your way to the beach on my
way yeah the lighting also just kind of
looks more natural it's like less gray
it's gonna be kind of hard for me to
keep up with them
the water for sure looks way better i
don't the the lighting on it previously
is like
you still got that same like kind of
white crippling
a rippling effect but
it's um looks way more natural
i do not have the gun in the same spot
this looks way better it's like
everything was just a lot blockier i
think in in the um the crisis one
version for sure
and i know yeah the the remastered
trilogy specifically has like improved
shadow technology which i feel is pretty
clear that's probably what's crazing to
let creating the less blocky look
especially when it's a clear dark knight
there's no reason that everything should
be as
as like highly contrasted as it looks in
the older version it just looks kind of
oh
so yeah there are shadows on glass and
particles and all that now too
[Music]
yeah this is way different
his face looks so much better
jesus
what the hell happened here
i mean obviously it's a remastered not a
remake so it does look like a remaster
you know it's it's
updated um
materials and textures and and the
vehicles have been improved the weapons
and the characters have been improved
but it's not like a completely new video
game
um it doesn't
i don't like this man
that's fine dude
i know what happens right after here i
played this game so recently
pretty sure it's here pretty sure
[ __ ]
life comes at you fast
yeah it's the whole game's just way way
way brighter as well which is which is
nice
just see a whole lot more
very cool all right i think at this
point we will jump to crisis two oh no
hang on let's let's get to the beach
first just to see the difference between
those two
all righty we have jumped over to crysis
2. again everything is at the highest
setting uh dlss on
ultra ray tracing very high
and these two especially with the
remaster trilogy are software and
hardware based and i know the next gen
versions also have improved vegetation
shading and 60fps animations on uh
weapons and water ripple effects too
so let's hit apply
game
no that's all good
back
um campaign new campaign
we're gonna go soldier
and we are going to get started
the color is really different can you
describe any uh visible
signature
wow
oh that was way better that that water
effect that was way improved
tell him alcatraz
alcatraz are you talking much this
morning
contrary to popular belief people
tequila is not good for your health
ah it's like the change in the contrast
i mean i'm sure it's textures as well
like he like has more paws now you know
their faces look way better
you don't call force recon for an emad
evac
they're bad guys up there
i swear
i can feel it get the hell off listen up
marines
what the [ __ ] was that
explosions are less blown out for sure
um
oh
that's way more detail
down
alcatraz blast down
especially cool
what happened
just don't touch them
hey
that's not a good time
hostiles you call it
oh boy
and it floated faster
would you love to see
oh this lighting is way nicer
like softness of it
oh this stuff looks so much nicer
pop it
it's gold you read me damn profit
it weirdly looks more homely like it
looks more like a place that i would
actually want to go
prophet
listen to me
i don't know if you can hear this but
they're coming for you you have to find
those marines there's something like
weirdly fun about trying to match up to
somebody else's gameplay
how you doing bud
[Music]
all right i reckon we could probably
leave this here
crisis two that's a pretty good showcase
let's jump over
to crisis three shall we
very high apply gonna go to advanced
graphics everything on very high i mean
there are literally hundreds of unique
cpu and gpu performance improvements
uh across all three games and frankly
you love to see it um but i had such a
good time playing this game i i don't
think i got all the achievements but i
think i was pretty damn close
because of that predator combined with
the suit was so much fun
lcs this is 103. be advised we picked up
rebel movements through dome
oh the water looks way better
nothing getting on this boat tonight
over
damn this looks
really good
not that the old version didn't look
really good but wow
it's like cinematic
this i can't believe the amount of
detail on this like even in the rain i
feel like not a lot of video games show
this much
density in the rain
that makes sense
[Music]
i feel like this looks i i need to look
up when this game came out but
just as
good as a 2021 video game like genuinely
that's like stunning
silencer on
always
that was a bit messy
it was
it's so cool
yeah
makes you an invisible silent killing
machine
serious kid i didn't realize that you
got it that early no yes
it has enough kinetic energy to stop a
rhino dead
with interchangeable heads you can drop
an explosive charge on any target and
best of all you stay cloaked
you like it now
i'm coming around
good it's so
good
let's go
all right mate let's go
romeo one we've breached foxtrot four
burnout prepped and ready
nice one
see what i mean
ah this game did not get
the credit it deserved for that kind of
[ __ ]
that can kill you from anywhere man
a lot of you is dead
anywhere
um all right i think i'm gonna leave it
there
um obviously the video game
it looked very good ugh but at this
point i'm literally just playing because
i think crisis 3 is
stupid fun because of this bow if you've
not played it please do check it out it
is awesome so yeah there'll be a link in
the description to where you can grab
the game for yourself if you would like
to it released on the 15th on pc
nintendo switch current and next-gen
playstation and xbox consoles 49.99 in
both dollars and euros pounds is 44.99
um it is a wonderful wonderful trilogy
i'm a really big fan and uh it's it i'm
hey i'm glad it runs
the link will be in the description huge
thanks to crytek for sponsoring this
video bye